fox news alert a bombshell new report
suggesting biden's botched exit from
afghanistan was even worse than we
thought according to the new york times
the isis terrorists that biden
supposedly droned in retaliation for the
airport attack in kabul was not an isis
terrorist after all
he was a u.s aid worker
in his rush to clean up the mess his
incompetence caused at the airport where
13 u.s service members lost their lives
he authorized a drone strike on the
wrong guy and likely killed several
children as well
video uncovered by the time shows that
the aid worker was not loading bombs
into his car
he was loading bottles of water joining
me now are two afghanistan war vets my
fellow fox and friends weekend co-host
pete hegseth and sean parnell retired
army infantry captain
pete we were on the air when that drone
stroke occurred and we actually thought
okay maybe he's finally getting
something right here
but we were wrong
your reaction
it appears it appears we may be i mean
first of all rachel i'm always skeptical
yeah of the new york times i'm always
skeptical of international journalists
given free access in the now taliban
controlled kabul you don't have this
kind of extensive reporting without the
approval of the taliban so they're
trying to even if it's joe biden they're
trying to make america look bad a number
one
but if this reporting is correct then
indeed everything you're saying is
correct which is in their haste to make
it look like they're doing something
they pushed and pushed and pushed and
potentially killed a aid worker who was
working on behalf of the united states
which leads to the fact that
i i have zero confidence in joe biden as
a commander-in-chief especially
considering the fact that we had threat
reporting on the airport at the abbey
gate in the time period in which our
marines were still allowed to to gather
the way that they did and sean parnell
knows as well as anybody if you have a
threat active on a location you have two
choices go on the offense and create a
new perimeter change the dynamics or
re-fortify your position and they did
neither so this is a cascading set of
decisions by the by administration and
now if this reporting is true
tragically in their in their desire to
make themselves look good they didn't
improve the security situation at all
and the wrong people are dead yeah it's
really tragic
sean i want to play this clip if i could
from our
defense secretary lloyd austin who is
now concerned that we're going to have
more terrorism not less
following this withdrawal take a listen
the whole community is kind of watching
to see what happens and whether or not
al qaeda
has the ability to uh to regenerate in
afghanistan the nature of al qaeda and
isis k is that you know they will always
attempt to uh to find space to uh to
grow and regenerate whether it's there
whether it's in somalia whether it's in
any un
any other ungoverned space
sean how much of this increase in
terrorism that we're now hearing not
just
austin talk about but also general
milley and i don't know how much of this
is cya but you know we're seeing that
there's an increase now i mean is it
worse are we in a worse position today
on the eve of the 20th anniversary of 9
11 than we were maybe even when this
whole thing started
yeah tragically i think that we are and
you can lay all of this at joe biden's
feet and he basically in in in a part of
this tragic withdrawal in afghanistan he
basically control he basically installed
a terrorist super state in afghanistan
so as part of the taliban interim
government is a guy named siraj shakani
sriracha connie has a 10 million dollar
state department bounty on his head joe
biden is openly negotiating with
organizations like the taliban with
hekmatyar with the akani network aiding
and abetting terrorist groups on the eve
of 9 11.
rachel if that is not something that is
resignation worthy if that is not
something that is impeachment worthy
that that i don't know what is and and i
think unfortunately our world is is far
more as a far more dangerous place now
uh not because we left afghanistan but
because of the way we left afghanistan
and the fact that we have basically a
geriatric walking foreign policy
disaster as our commander-in-chief and
so yes the world is more dangerous
leading into the 20th anniversary of
september 11th
pete the humiliating way in which we
left afghanistan and it was humiliating
how much more painful
is 911 is this 20th anniversary how much
more painful is biden making it for
americans
well very much so especially since he
attempted originally to set the date on
9 11 and then realized that was a
terrible idea but instead moved it
forward and exacerbated the problem
completely you know what i'm trying to
do rachel and we're going to be live on
the air tomorrow with fox and friends
i'm doing my best to separate the
absolute sheer incompetence of what
biden has unraveled in afghanistan which
sean said so well
from the recognition that the heroes
deserve for this day 20 years later and
the desperate plea that we not forget
and the desperate plea that we not take
our eye off the fact that there are
radical islamists still to this day that
seek our destruction that now have a
mega terror state in afghanistan and
ultimately if we forget what their goals
are which is the destruction of the west
we will be incapable in future
generations of addressing it not to
mention threats like the communist
chinese so yes joe biden has made it
eminently worse sean is totally right
but tomorrow is a day to remember so
that we have the abilities maybe sort of
possibly to muster a response should we
need to which looks more likely in the
future
pete
shawn thank you very much for joining me